are going to begin today with the
intensifying effort to fight the
disturbing surge in new covet cases
especially among those
who have not been vaccinated the
department of veterans affairs has
announced it is requiring most of its
medical workers
to be vaccinated and that's the first
federal agency to take this step
workers who deal directly with patients
now have eight weeks
to get fully vaccinated or they could
lose their jobs
nancy cordes is at the white house with
more on this story nancy good morning to
is this a sign of things to come do you
think
it sure sounds like it gail and it is a
surprise because the biden
administration
has been so skittish about the idea of a
federal vaccine mandate but now
with covid cases rising again the va
is doing just that as are california and
new york city creating a model for other
states and cities and agencies
to follow it is the nation's largest
integrated health care system with more
than 300 medical centers and clinics
serving more than 9 million veterans now
all medical personnel who
work in or even visit va facilities
must get their shots by mid-september
veteran affairs
is going to in fact require that all
docs working in
facilities are going to have to be
vaccinated the new mandate was
issued the same day that nearly 60
medical associations
called on all health care facilities to
require that workers get
vaccinated to reduce the harmful toll
this virus is taking
within the workforce this is about
keeping people safe
new york city's new mandate requires all
city workers
prove they're vaccinated or take weekly
covid tests
starting september 13th the same will go
for california state workers
and those who work in health care
homeless shelters
jails and other high risk settings
individuals choice
not to get vaccinated is now impacting
the rest of us
the v.a move was a turnaround just last
week the white house was insisting
national mandates aren't the answer
that's not the role of the federal
government
nationwide new covid cases increased
more than
20 percent in the past week due to the
more contagious delta variant
still just 51 percent of americans
believe
employers should require vaccines within
hours of new york city's announcement
the firefighters union was
already pushing back and this union will
stand against and fight any mandate to
vaccinate new york city firefighters
against their wills
justice department attorneys released
their opinion yesterday that
federal law doesn't prevent public
agencies or
private businesses from mandating
vaccines and in fact
public maxine vaccine mandates are
nothing
new the first one took place in the
early
1900s during the smallpox epidemic
anthony all right nancy thank you